okay folks we need to talk about
cannibal babies and how this relates to
the resurrection this is Jonathan pezzo
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
so last week on Twitter there is a
medieval scholar his name is Eric Wade
who published a thread and I don't even
know how it is that I ended up seeing
this thread but somehow someone shared
it or liked it or whatever and so it
came up in front of me I have since then
followed him because he has some haha he
is definitely worth following in order
to see a certain strand of thinking and
so Eric Wade talked about the problem of
cannibal babies he asked the questions
if our bodies are resurrected in the
Last Judgement what happens if we were
eaten now Eric Wade is a medieval
scholar who describes itself as a
medievalist helicopter parent to a kitty
queer studying sex race in Oh a
literature lecturer at the University of
Bonn I guess and so what we're going to
see and it's going to be very
interesting is we're going to notice
that how first of all I I have some
sympathy for him because it is very
difficult to understand medieval
thinking today but we'll also see in his
thread is a desire to show his own
virtue a virtue signaling if you will
and a mocking of the ancients a way of
making fun of their thinking and his own
virtue signaling will prevent him
interestingly enough from seeing some of
the deeper meaning that could be
involved in this question of the
cannibal baby and I say this laughing
because obviously this is this is fringe
stuff but it is indeed fringe stuff and
understanding the fringe is something
that I've been doing with you guys from
the beginning and so it'll actually help
us to understand the fringe so let's
look at what he says so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna read his post I'm gonna
I'm gonna post a link to his thread in
the comment section if you want to read
the whole thing I'm gonna read his post
and you can then read if you want later
the quotes that he quotes from st.
Augustine and from Thomas Aquinas and so
he goes medieval Christians delusions
were obsessed with
cannibal baby question if our body our
resident bodies are resurrected in the
Last Judgement what happens if we were
eaten they thought God would extract the
you matter from the cannibals body and
the cannibal would be resurrected using
whatever other matter their body was
made of God keeps tracks of the tiny
bits that you are and puts them back
together even if you are eaten or burned
up but medieval theologians have the
bigger problem cannibal babies what if
two cannibals eat you and they have a
baby made entirely out of substance from
consume flesh how will God resurrect the
baby and you if you are made of the same
matter will the baby's substance turn
into you now what's interesting to see
here is obviously Eric Wade thinks this
is funny and he's using this as a way to
mock medieval Christians and first of
all the first thing that is interesting
to note is that someone like himself
would spend his entire life studying the
medieval world and then would do that it
would spend his entire life basically
talking about things that he that he
wants to mock and make fun of imagine
that life imagine a life which is based
on on studying something studying only
something that you wish to make fun of
but I digress alright and so he talks
about how that most of theologians said
that God who could just make up new
matter and you no big deal but some of
the theologians were very concerned with
the question tried to look at it in a
more technical way all right and so here
he talks about st. Augustine he says st.
Augustine didn't really think we are
made out of what we eat and anyway if
you eat a little bit of someone else
because you're hungry or whatever I mean
who hasn't that flesh evaporates into
air and floats around until the
resurrection we're surrounded by flesh
vapor it's cool now he I'll quote a
little bit of saying st. Augustine here
because it'll help you see something
about what he's doing for someone
famishing for want and pressed with
hunger uses human flesh as food an
extremity not unknown as both ancient
history and the unhappy experience of
our own days have taught us Kenny
be contended with any sort of reason
that all the flesh eaten has been
evacuated and that none of it has been
assimilated to the substance of the
eater and so then Eric Wade says for
Augustine the human that you ate because
you were hungry and extremity not
unknown in these times whom some of us
has not had to eat someone is like a
lone and you have to give it you have to
give their flesh back but God will give
you other flesh so no skin off anyone's
back chill out now I want you to notice
one thing in what Eric Wade is doing is
that he is making fun of Augustine he is
suggesting that Augustine is talking
about cannibalism in in a normal way
that he is normalizing cannibalism
suggesting of course humorously not
directly that maybe Augustine is a
cannibal if he thinks that cannibalism
is so normal you know hey who amongst us
has not eaten human flesh and so he is
mocking the idea that possibly Agostini
he's doing mockingly away suggesting
that a hog is seen maybe as a cannibal
you know if he is talking about it in a
normal manner all right okay so this was
largely the party line until the late
Middle Ages Thomas Aquinas thought a lot
about the cannibal baby issue and
whether a baby made entirely of
cannibalized flesh we just get divided
up into its former bodies in the Last
Judgement so Tom's view was that if the
cannibal had ever eaten anything else or
if their parents had then God just used
that matter but the baby born of people
on econo cannibalism only died presented
Tom with the same problem as he
presented everyone if you are a strict
cannibal Thomas argued but your parents
weren't then God would just restore the
matter that came from your parents
specifically your father's semen and
then supplement it with some extra new
matter but if you're a strict cannibal
and your parents were then Thomas
equated Thomas Aquinas thought that God
just fudged it the part of you made from
your father's semen even if the semen
was originally someone your dad ate
would be restored as your body so if
you're eaten by cannibal who then has
sex with another cannibal and part of
your eatin body turns into the semen
that makes a cannibal baby
sorry you don't get that little bit of
yourself back it belongs to the baby now
God will replace that matter with new
matter and then here comes the virtue
signal now pay attention now until now
he has been making fun of the idea of
the Resurrection because it is obviously
and I'm not pretending that I understand
the resurrection he's obviously very
difficult to understand what it is that
if it's if we're talking about a final
state of the humanics of the human state
which includes all the elements which is
a let's say a a culmination of all its
elements which should also include the
body that is the totality of the of your
person also includes your body so if you
view though if you view the moment of
totality of yourself it should also
include your body and so the that is
what they're trying to deal with we're
going to look at the meaning of what it
could mean a little bit later but until
now that's what he's been kind of making
fun of but then here comes the here
comes the attack Christians were very
anxious about these scenarios the
anxiety would hand-in-hand with racist
projections of cannibalism on to
non-christians especially Jews and
Muslims who were accused of ritual
cannibalism ironic given ritual
cannibalism in Catholicism the Eucharist
Geraldine's hangs wonderful book Empire
of magic looks at these racist anxieties
as well as the actual historical
cannibalism that European Crusader did
in the Levant and at romances like Emme
Richard Kelly Leo in which King Richard
eats Muslims as a joke
now now want to notice what he's doing
here and so he's saying Christians used
to project cannibalism onto
non-christians and and he's saying that
that is you know this kind of other ring
of the non-christians and you know
dehumanizing the
Christian has been cannibals which is
ironic because they themselves
participated in the Eucharist which was
a form of cannibalism
now notice like I said notice what he's
doing I have said many times that if you
want to understand the progressive
mindset if you want to understand it you
have to you can compare it to the
traditional mindset traditional people
especially like traditional European
people tend to demonize that which is
outside of their identity they tend to
to dehumanize that which is outside the
outside of their group you know and
that's an unfortunate side effect of
identity progressives what they do is
they dehumanize those that were there
before them they tend to see people in
the Middle Ages as idiots as kind of you
know more closer to apes closer to those
you know we've now evolved we've
progressed further and so it's actually
the exact same structure if the
traditional mind were tended to to see
the people on the outside as closer to
animals the progressive mind tends to
see those that were before them as
closer to animals and so Eric Wade while
accusing while accusing tell it's saying
that the Christians accused the
outsiders of being cannibals he in his
own email is suggesting that Augustine
is a cannibal maybe not directly but
indirectly he's suggesting that
Augustine is normalizing cannibalism and
his mocking him because he's doing that
and so he is doing the exact same thing
himself as he is accusing others of
doing and this is just how the thing
works if you look at my work you'll
probably find that you will find the
exact same pattern these patterns of
other ring are universal they are very
difficult to avoid and so even if you
watch my videos you'll probably find me
doing that at some at some point but
it's interesting to notice that just as
he's accusing those medieval Christians
of being horribly racist and
dehumanizing he himself is mocking those
medieval Christians and humorously
suggesting that they
normalise cannibalism all right now then
he says cannibalism was also associated
with sodomites in fact Thomas Aquinas
called
sodomy a bestial vice that he associates
with cannibalism this may be because
sodomy was often associated with
non-christians Aquinas thought sodomy
meant male male sexual acts bestiality
and cannibalism now here is really where
this is really where he exposes the fact
that his own political tendency that his
own political desires are blinding him
to what the possible meaning of this
whole cannibal baby situation is
actually talking about now alright so
now we need to look at what this could
possibly mean now I have to first I have
to at first concede that it is extremely
difficult to understand some of this
stuff because we do not think exactly
the same way that the medievals think of
we do not think we do not think in terms
of this eschatological moment you know
as Christians we believe it but it's
very difficult for us to understand the
eschatological moment and so what I like
to do is to help you understand the
eschatological moment is to help people
see it ontological II is to help you
understand the actual ontological
structure of a being and and its
totality it's the totality of its
ontological structure and that can help
you understand what it is that these
medieval Christians are talking about
when they're talking about this final
restoration at the end which will be the
totality of of your of your being which
will restore the totality of your being
okay so let's look at the problem of
cannibalism in terms of this ontological
structure so for those of you who have
read Matthew's book towards the end this
will be very helpful to you to
understand what I'm going to be talking
about right now so now imagine you have
the human people the human nature right
human nature and sin if you read the
quotes of a Augustine and Thomas Aquinas
you'll see that
they talk about the substance of human
nature so human nature is a is does not
have manifestation doesn't is a it's a
principle it's a you know it's a logos
it's a it's an identity okay and so
human nature for it to exist needs body
it needs substance okay and so the the
human body is part of that substance and
in order to preserve that human body the
human person has to go outside of the
human body take things from the outside
and bring them in join them into the
their body in order for the body to
continue and so that's what eating is
eating is you are you have the human
person you have the human body and in
order for that to continue you
constantly have to go outside of
humanity you have to eat other animals
you have to eat vegetables you have to
eat things that are outside of your
identity in order for you to preserve
that body okay now the problem happens
what what happens if you now remain
within the the the identity
what happens if you self eat okay and so
a human person you eat ate you eat a
human body and so what you're doing is
you're actually you're breaking the
normal the normal relationship of
identity
you're breaking the ontological
hierarchy you are instead of instead of
you eating something which is outside of
human nature you're eating something
which is already the substance of human
nature so you're creating this loop
within within the structure instead of
it being a nice pyramid where you have
the human nature which is eating things
on the outside and and integrating it
into human as the substance of human
nature you are eating something which is
already the substance of human nature
and so it creates this this causal loop
okay and that really if that is the
that's the problem of the margin that's
the problem of the breakdown one of the
problems of the breakdown of identity is
is when there is this circularity when
there is this this causal loop and so if
you eat human body at some point you are
going to run out of body okay you are
going to exhaust the body right it's
hard to uh it's hard to understand it in
terms of of cannibalism let's look at it
in terms of self
let's if you look at it in terms of
incest it's probably a lot easier to
understand and so if you have a a father
who has a daughter and then has a child
with that daughter and then the the same
father would have a child with his
granddaughter right you're at some point
the causal loop has been completely
broken and so there is no more a normal
distribution of identity the father is
both the the father to his daughter the
husband to his daughter but then also
the the husband to his granddaughter and
so the granddaughters grandfather is
both her husband her father and her
grandfather right and so the normal
levels of causality amicably broken and
and the self eating this this this
remaining within the same group
constantly within the same group is
going to exhaust the body now if you
don't understand it ontologically if you
don't understand it metaphysically you
can at least understand it if you look
at those phenomena in the world today
that is that if we know that if you know
mad cow disease with cows eating other
cows at some point those cows become
insane and they they they break down the
cows break down when they self eat at
some point because they run out of body
the same thing happens with incest in
communities that are too tight and are
too close together then those
communities will at some point run out
of body that is that the genetic
material will be exhausted you have to
be getting potentiality from the outside
all the time in order for a system to
remain healthy if you if you shut down
the system at some point you run out of
body you know and so that if you
understand it that way you can
understand
I the problem of the cannibal baby was
so important because it was trying to
understand this problem of identity and
substance and how what happens if you
just self self consume you know and it
really is you know if you think of the
Ouroboros and the snake eating its own
tail and that this being on the edge of
the world
this being the image of chaos that is
what this that is what cannibalism is
the problem that it is talking about and
so there is also in in the Bible there
is also a way for this problem of
causality to act as a strange
restoration you know that although it is
this breakdown it also in some cases can
become a form of resurrection or form of
restoration and so that is why communion
that's part of why communion has an
aspect of cannibalism to it community is
not is not cannibalism in the strict
sense but it takes some of the symbolism
of cannibalism joins it with the Syst
the the the symbolism of productive
eating of eating normal food of
communion and all of that and by
bringing all those things together
that's what creates the totality that's
what creates the the the the
resurrection you see the same in the
Bible with the the laws of the levirate
which is that you are not allowed to
have to marry your brother's wife
because you married your brother's wife
you're breaking this this problem of
causality but when your brother died
then you could give a son to your
brother by marrying his his wife and so
by by using this self causality it it
acted as a kind of resurrection right we
talked about trampling down death by
death right now flipping death on its
head okay now it's really important to
understand that it's not that the that
the forms of that regular cannibalism or
that or that incest was with obviously
always a an unacceptable thing because
it does create that breakdown but
symbolically within a very strict in a
very strict context in the context of
communion or the context of the levirate
it was a manner to use this death to use
to use death to flip it back on itself
and to create a new life let's say and
so now if you look then at the the last
quote that he talks about sodomy and
talks about sodomites you know that that
he says it's probably because sodomy was
associated with non-christians if he
could only understand what I explained
to you then he would understand why
cannibalism is associated with sodomy
because because just like sodomy is self
love it is the love of one it is the
love of a man for another man it also
runs out of body it is a sterile
relationship it does not produce bodies
and the same way that if you self eat
cannibalism at some point exhausts body
and so if he had only understood that
the ontological discussion that is
happening and not only I'd looked at it
generously instead of only looking at
something to make it possible for him to
virtue signal to the world about how
woke he is and how horribly stupid those
medieval Christians were then maybe he
could understand something about the
nature of reality and how these things
how these things work so I know this was
a weird post in terms of cannibal baby
but I always like when I see something
very strange coming out of the Christian
tradition I always like to to explain it
in order to help you understand how
these patterns work and so as usual
please go ahead and comment below you
know get involved in the discussion
there is like I've told you before
there's always also a Facebook group in
which you can discuss these things and
yeah guys I promised you a video on
credit and and it is coming but it's
very difficult to think about this stuff
so I I will put it together soon and I
thought that in the meat
this small video on cannibal babies
would be interesting so I'll see you
soon
if you enjoy the symbolic world content
there's a lot of things you can do to
help us out if you're not subscribed
please do go ahead and share this to all
your friends if you can get involved in
the discussion we have a Facebook group
in which people can talk about these
subjects I will put all those links in
the description and also if you can
please support us financially by going
to my website
www.ihaveaspergers.webs.com